- Joining us now from Baltimore,
Dr. Tom Inglesby, Director
of the Center
for Health Security at Johns
Hopkins University.
Doctor, I know you watched
the rally last night
from a public health standpoint,
if not a political one.
I guess the good news
was there wasn't as big
a crowd as expected.
But as an epidemiologist
watching that rally last night,
what did you see?
Yeah, I thought that the rally
was concerning in terms
of public health risk.
I mean, CDC's recent guidance
was that the highest risk
gatherings are those that are
large, indoors, where people
can't stay apart
from each other more than six
feet, and where people travel
from out of town.
And this rally met all
of those criteria.
And what I saw was that people
were sitting quite close
to each other, didn't see very
many people wearing masks.
There were some people
handshaking without hand
sanitizer, lots of shouting.
All of those things
will increase the risk
of spread.
CHRIS WALLACE: Given all
of that, does the president's
rally in Tulsa
have the potential
to be a super spreader
of the virus?
We have seen
in the past few months
around the world
that indoor gatherings have been
the source of most
super spreading events.
And those are events where one
person can give it to--
give the virus to many people,
so there's an opportunity
for much more spread
in a short period of time.
So I am worried about that.
I know that many people
in the public health community
are worried about the potential
for a big spreading event.
I want to pick up on that
because a number
of conservatives
point out
that a lot of the media,
and even some public health
experts, not you, but some
of your colleagues
didn't express the same concerns
when there were tens
of thousands
of people taking to the streets
in protests
over the death of George
Floyd, many of them
not wearing masks.
Is-- is there some hypocrisy
where public health concerns
depend upon the politics
of the gathering that's being
held?
Well, they shouldn't depend
on the gathering that's being
held.
I think the public health
principles are the same
whether it's for one purpose
or another.
I certainly sympathize
with the motivations of the--
the demonstrations that have
gone on across the country,
but I do worry that they are
an opportunity for spread.
I think it's a little bit--
it were even more than a little
bit different than having
a large indoor gathering.
We know that outdoor risks are
less than indoor risks.
And if people can maintain
their space, then that will
help.
But certainly, I think there is
a risk
with large-scale protesting,
as well, for increased spread.
Let me ask you about that
because there has been some
testing of protesters after
the big-- after the big events
in Minneapolis and New York.
And at least so far,
and I understand the incubation
period goes on, there has not
been any clear spike detected
as a result of those.
Is it possible
that public health experts are
exaggerating the risk
from these big public
gatherings?
I don't think they're
exaggerating the risks.
I do think, again, that
it's-- we know from what
we've seen so far in the last
few months that outdoors is less
of a risk than indoors and that
mask use has a major impact.
So to the extent that people are
wearing masks
in a particular gathering,
that will help a lot.
And it is also a little bit
too soon to say whether or not
the protests have led
to increased cases, although I
am very glad to see
that the initial studies do show
that there doesn't seem to be
an increased rate of spread.
It's quite
different in an indoor setting
where people are sitting
shoulder to shoulder
for a prolonged period of time
and really in close quarters
like that.
Every time you come on,
I ask you where are we
with the coronavirus cases.
And I want to put up a map that
shows the fact that while there
are significant decreases
in a lot of the places
that were hit earliest
and hardest,
there are now
21 states in the West
and in the South that are seeing
at least a 25% increase
in new cases.
Dr. Inglesby, how much of that
do you think is just the fact
that we're testing more people?
How much of that do you think
is the fact that maybe we're
reopening too soon?
And how much
of that do you think is--
that there is, in fact,
a spread,
a spike in the virus in some
of these states
where there has been reopening?
I think it's a combination
of more testing and a real--
an important spike,
in many cases,
in many-- many states
across the country.
And you can distinguish what
is more testing from what
is more serious disease
from looking at hospitalization
rate, ICU rate, and the percent
positivity of the overall tests
in a given state.
And in many states, in the ones
that you just showed,
particularly Arizona, Texas,
the Carolinas, Florida, what
we're seeing
is increased positivity,
and testing, and, in many cases,
increased hospitalizations,
so serious illness happening.
That's not just because we're
doing more testing in a state.
That's because there is more
serious disease in a state.
So that's a rise.
And do you think some
of those--
That's a real rise
and [INAUDIBLE]
Do you think some
of those states, Doctor,
should--
should pull back on
the reopening, should-- should,
you know,
if they're in phase two,
go back to phase one,
or even go back
into partial lockdowns?
I don't think we need to go
into lockdown in these places
at this point.
I think each state has
a different story.
Each state has its own reopening
process, and they're all
slightly different.
I do think that governors should
be guiding their-- their public
to avoid large gatherings, where
we see the greatest
potential risk.
They should also be really
strongly encouraging people--
leaders should be encouraging
people to use the tools that we
know work.
We should be encouraging people
to wear face coverings,
to stay at a distance,
to avoid large gatherings,
to use hand sanitizer
or wash your hands.
I mean, those are the things
that we know work, and leaders
really should, I think,
double down in communicating
that across the country.
Those are the things that we
have seen work and will work.
President Trump talked
this week about the virus,
the spread of the virus
and also
about medical treatments.
Here he is on that.
DONALD TRUMP: We're very
close to a vaccine,
and we're very
close to therapeutics, really
good therapeutics.
And but even without that--
I don't even like to talk
about that because it's fading
away.
It's going to fade away.
Is the coronavirus fading
away?
Are we close, very close,
to a vaccine?
And the World Health
Organization said this week
that we are in a-- let me get it
right--
"a new and dangerous phase"
of COVID-19.
Best case, best case, how long
are we going to be living
and dealing with this virus?
Well, the first thing to say
is it's not fading away.
The US has more cases than it's
had in many, many weeks.
If you compare us to other parts
of the world, our numbers
are on the rise.
The European Union-- last--
last week, we had 25,000 cases
in a particular day,
and the European Union had 4,000
cases.
So it's not fading away
in the US.
It's not fading away
in the world.
There's something on the order
of 70 or 80 countries
where the virus is on the rise.
So it's
a serious, serious pandemic.
And as the WHO said,
we are in a new phase
of intensity in many parts
of the world.
Vaccine development is going
as quickly as it's ever gone
for any vaccine in the world.
And there are a couple
of vaccine trials
that are really ramping up
in the next month.
So that's all good news.
But we don't know yet
whether and when that vaccine
will work.
We hope we'll have vaccine
by the end of this year,
but I don't think we can count
on it yet.
So I think people really need
to focus on what they can do
to decrease transmission
while we wait for a vaccine
and continue to do
the things that we know work
in terms of preventing spread.
Dr. Inglesby, thank you.
Thanks for your time
on this Father's Day.
Always good to talk with, sir.